[Music]
if I'm here to publicize my foundation
as well thanks for having me
Kona the David O'Doherty foundation we
provide tiny keyboards to children in
disasters struck areas thank you you
honor you want to see their faces when I
come over the hill in the truck they're
like at last fresh water medicine I'm
like isn't helping this song is called
life life life life life life life
ile-ife life life life life life life
life life no no actually it's okay
oh no it's not oh god no you're not
serious no not this again aah no aah and
then you die
life is a marathon not a sprint but it's
a sort of marathon that you have to
spread and the turtles and weights to
lift and cycling an archery life is
basically Olympics and you don't get a
medal you die life
it's like going out with Emily from the
movie Amelie in distance it seems like
it should be really fulfilling and
satisfying but actually on a day-to-day
basis it's quite annoying
hey Emily can you sorted the direct
deposit for the gas in the new apartment
no because they got to be to pay pay off
and I made it into an origami swan and I
put it on the river Oh God
it's adorable for the first few months
but now it's a real pain like it's hard
you know it's just not spoken about for
a few songs but life being hard just
about how brilliant everything is I'm
walking on sunshine it's a beautiful day
from now on every single song should
have to have at least one reference to
life being hard every single song happy
birthday to you happy birthday
the rate of prostate cancer in men over
the age of 85 is 100% an actual doctor
told me that recently a leading cancer
specialist she said the cells are benign
in some men but like over the age of 80
Bledington because no talks that are
being hard I think you think you're the
only one who finds that hot
I bet everyone finds it equally hard
even people who seem outwardly really
content and satisfied bet even Roger
Federer the tennis player with the
massive hat about once a year he's
sitting at some change events and he
looks down at his little banana in one
hand and his tennis racquet me looks up
and see the umpire in the highchair and
he sees the ring of giant novelty tennis
balls around the stub of the top of the
stadium and just for a moment I bet even
Roger Federer thinks to himself I'm 34
years old what the hell am I doing with
my life just a game like Hungry Hungry
Hippos
don't get me wrong it's brilliant bits
like when you see something haven't seen
for a while or you get drunk
unexpectedly it over a cycle with a win
behind or you read a book that's
incredible where you go to an
unbelievable show but very often when
you go back inside again you find that
someone set your bike on fire that
actually happened to me recently that is
not a metaphor
it was the charity gig I came out after
a charity gig and there's like 20 bikes
part is that steam coming what are the
bikes someone had said my bike on fire
wha why you said house even stand a bike
on fire
aha it was raining that's the real
miracle
Oh Dublin somewhere over the rainbow
event life is just exactly as hard as it
is on this side of the rainbow and on
that side you can't even see the rainbow
you know that optically you know what I
mean it's like to do with the you know
the like get up pink floyd--
maybe it's even more homophobic on the
other side of the rainbow
let's just stay on this side that's all
of us even just for tonight let's just
have a nice time
[Music]
[Applause]
you